how many years have we all known each
other now it's Pages yeah quite a while
it's been numb because I remember
distinctly the first time I met you two
and you we met at the Anime Expo like
2017. was that the attitude of Meetup
yes yeah I remember that and I remember
you specifically Joey because you came
up to me and you were like hi
you're like really hot
and I still stand by that Tuesday
so yeah we've all been friends for quite
a while uh because I would say we are
some of the ogs now of the anime YouTube
Community I know you hate being called a
nanny tuber now I don't care
whatever yeah yeah I think at this point
I've just given up on trying to Define
anything
yeah and I remember back then John just
didn't show his face at all right and I
think it might have been like the first
time I'd seen your face and I'm like no
Annie tuber should be this hot what the
[__] this is because I remember at that
attitude Meetup uh it was like it was
pretty sizable maybe around like you
know 40 50 people I kind of showed up
but it was really funny because I'd say
the majority of the people who were
there were just like all right which
one's super hypertual I have to see his
face and everyone was like yo he's mad
hot that's crazy see like like I didn't
know that that was going to be a thing
at all like I've been with my girlfriend
and wife Michelle for 18 years never
even really like date it around or
anything yeah yeah and so I talk about
doing like a face reveal to my friends
and they're like it's gonna be so funny
and I'm like what do you mean
and so then like I remember I put a Face
Reveal video up and I hit refresh and
there was immediately 70 comments and
the first one was oh no he's hot and the
second one was all capital letters old
and I was like
I was like oh this maybe this was a
mistake yeah
but uh yeah I mean you got your start I
guess
oh God yeah God damn yeah I remember
seeing this and I was like how did your
jawline get better because what the [__]
how does that happen yeah it's great
because I Look At You John I'm like all
right I have I have hope I have hope I
have hope in my life you know you hit
your 30s and you can still learn the son
of guts
[Music]
you started anime YouTube uh for a
pretty interesting reason right because
you did it out of spite oh yeah
completely my entire career is built on
hatred and basically I was like um I was
listening to woolly versus
um and he was talking on podcast about
so I started talking about Hunter Hunter
which for me top three anime of all time
I absolutely [__] love it right Joe
and hey I've read it now so oh you've
read it now now I understand good stuff
and um he's like
he's not like
just talking [__] he's going in like
he's like I can't deal with this tedious
Shonen horseshit and I'm like I'm
sitting there at like your average video
game podcast listener just [__]
seething and I'm just like how can you
see that with the anime I like and I
feel like um the healthy thing to do
would have just been to let it go yeah
that is not what I did
um I held on to it for a year and then
made a video called why you should watch
Hunter Hunter not about how he was wrong
because I thought that might be kind of
shitty but just about how I thought it
was good yeah and then also how here was
wrong I don't mean Loki did you mention
it all in the video sorry did you
mention him at all no all right I
thought so no and
um so that was the whole plan you know
that was the whole plan I'm gonna make
this video and then I'm gonna go back to
my actual life I can walk away from this
yeah because and um and then that didn't
happen right and mainly just because
like I really just [__] loved making
videos yeah I remember watching this
video and it came out yeah I was I think
I was around when I binged Hunter Hunter
so it was like kind of perfect time yeah
it was kind of crazy as well because you
almost just like came out of nowhere and
then I feel in a very short span of time
your name was just kind of floating
around in the attitude like whoa where
it's just like this is like new guy who
made this like Hunter Hunter video and
it's like really [__] good and no one
knows where he came from he just like
suddenly popped up yeah and I think a
part of it was like I wasn't on any like
forums or a part of any Community or
stuff like that because people would be
asking me like what's your model list
and all any of that kind of thing
back then oh you like anime give me your
malice
and but I just I [__] loved making
videos you know it just clicked in a way
that nothing else had and like I had
tried so much [__] up to that point you
know I had I like I'd been part of an
electronic like a band I tried to be an
illustrator I tried to be a storyboard
artist I spent six months training as a
wrestler all this kind of stuff and like
it always felt like pushing a boulder
uphill yeah and then when I started
YouTube I was like oh there's something
about this that I get that I don't get
about other things you know that kind of
way one thing so I think when I
discovered your content wasn't actually
the hunter hunter
it was actually the bleach video that
you did uh yes and I got asked we go
through this sorry if you walk me
through this side okay okay so John did
a video basically detailing uh I guess
uh I think the original was like the
fall of bleach correctly yep uh how did
the bleach fandom react to that because
I I wanna I wanna ask about sorry what
fandoms you've pissed off this video is
just you saying that it just fell off
yeah pretty much so originally actually
really positive right I had like kind of
like bleach YouTubers being like Oh it's
cool to see such an interesting like
look and breakdown but unfortunately
what I didn't know over time is like
basically I was basing it all on the
Shonen Jump chapter index long story
short yeah no one [__] knows what's
going on there's no like so I basically
read on a website I think it works like
this and then said in my video it works
like this and that earned me the ire of
the bleach fandom for Ever After yeah 13
000 comments
and the video like it sucked because
like I was really happy of with like the
how that video came together and like
how it told a story it just happens that
the story it was telling was wrong
um and I feel like I have tried to
correct that in various ways over the
years and never been successful so at
some point I'm like okay
I've never seen that
I can
I can confidently yes because I feel
like the top card is they're proud
damaged people retaliating at anything
out of survival
here's the thing that pisses me off
right right I [__] love
which is awesome like I yeah personally
I think it goes downhill over time I
will take bleach over Demon Slayer over
hero Academia over so much [__] it's
[__] great yeah and the only reason I
talk about it is because I give a [__]
but like look I did get it wrong and
that did piss people off so I don't want
to be dismissive of that you know yeah
because I feel like a rite of passage
with like anyone who does anime content
on YouTube or at least one is like we
talk about anime series it's like we at
least piss off one fandom within our
journey right of course uh Joe I think
I've nailed about eight or nine
three oh [__]